you guys remember the uh
uh butthole
chocolates cast the chocolate ass yeah
well someone on the ship decided to
um do that no [__] way filmed it so I
didn't know if you wanted to do it in
Maine or in bonus
um do you want to watch it in Maine and
and
watch it it's censored yeah
okay is this even like legal well that's
why I said that's why I wanted to give
you the options of like do you want to
do it in a bonus but I think we'd be
safe in Maine if you want to
it's censored it's it's was it you no
we'll tell you do you want to do it now
or you want to say it for later what
when did we do the other one when we
made the chocolates yeah I feel like we
should do it then all right so let's
bring out who who well yeah let's just
bring out whoever it was
yeah yeah yeah yeah did you actually do
it [__] eating grin
fresh off the Ukrainian front lines
wow everyone is my producer Alex former
assistant upgrade did you actually do it
oh yeah
we had we had a couple tries what do you
mean a couple tries we had a long
conversation about this and I asked him
who you do it with cash no do you want
to play the clip I think we should just
play the clip okay play the clip
oh God you don't want to talk about who
oh we can get there we can get there
Alex you [__] met
a position I never wanted to see you
and here's the [__] up thing he does
this in my house
[Laughter]
this is the longest person I've ever met
dude and I'm not talking about his dick
he's just he's built like a [__]
Cricket like
laughs
who's saying higher well we'll see my
girl off Tinder
what not always two two I'm serious a
random girl off Tinder a random girl off
Tinder yeah yeah
she was so into it it I had a couple
girls match and they were into it and
then they ghosted me and then one time I
was gonna like I was on the way to the
bar and she just bailed and then this
girl came and saved it all
on the way to the bar yeah I was like on
the way
on the wind
I don't blame you you're like my my
butthole's getting cold like this for
[__] two hours nah hold up you were
gonna go drink with these people and
then go do it that's what happened yeah
yeah like we went to it we got a couple
drinks like we hit it off wait did you
tell her did you tell her on Tinder
beforehand oh yeah my profile I can read
my profile oh you made a special profile
yeah yeah I mean like I gotta deal with
this kid's insane so oh yeah here's the
profile
or it says need help making a chocolate
mold of my butthole serious inquiries
only
even if you don't think I'm funny
parentheses impossible you'll be
relieved to know that I'm 6'3 which is
which is a fact
right now if you're five nine you would
have not got this done yeah I promise
you that oh my God if you're five nine
there's no shot you would have got this
done all right let's continue I forgot
you were gonna do this I'm proud of you
I cannot believe that this is real I
hang out with Alex for a couple months
and you can
trust me there's nothing to not believe
about this man
those are some photos
oh yeah oh yeah
oh man you are getting old you're
pulling out young pictures
getting there like I thought you were a
soccer player I was one of the girls
responded she was like that purple this
shirt and the purple photo that was like
five years ago yeah I was like yeah
all right so the uh the misses you
landed on yeah
um she Who Shall Not Be Named no she
does not want to be named so she she hit
you up and was like is this a joke no no
so we matched and I messaged her first
and she said something about cats I was
like don't worry I've got a cat like at
school I'm not allergic but I'm hoping
you saw my bio and she was like oh yeah
I saw it and she swiped right yeah yeah
all she saw was six three yeah and dude
it's like moth to a flame you put six
three yeah yeah
did you actually read it though she's
like well I mean I saw the numbers yeah
yeah the numbers part of it yeah that's
what do you mean girls are really good
at math yeah
yeah yeah
oh my God and so you said did you see my
buyer she was like yes yeah yeah you
know be a funnier like and you're like
this is serious yeah I mean it said
serious and queries only so I was trying
to call anybody because that makes it
sad
you know be a really fun experiment
after this put that same bio up and
change it to five right change the five
seven and see how many replies you get
okay so mold one you [__] pervert
[__] creep okay up up higher higher
I hate this dude yeah
[Laughter]
I actually I asked Jersey like Trump
voice cannot believe just pour the cup
into it yeah
that's it that's just right there yeah
[Laughter]
cup we have the best one that's a nice
cup here's what we're what we're looking
at oh yeah um oh yeah let's clarify to
the audience what we're looking at um
it's Al it's my producer Alex lying on
his back and a girl fisting his ass
which it very well could be we can't
really tell it's completely all we see
is it's like
like this Shin part of his legs yeah and
his upper and his like lower thigh the
thing is on his back legs over his head
and
like through the blur you can kind of
see this girl is doing something to his
ass I'm just following the instructions
that's the position they told me yeah
and here's the other thing about Alex is
he's so quick to demonstrate things like
this and he wears shortly you see shorts
now they're so short I'm ready to go I
was ready to give you a demonstration
right here this really isn't that
off-putting to me because I've seen him
do this in my place a multitude of times
right right right him and Alina were in
like a month-long argument about
missionary and he just kept having a lie
on his back and demonstrate I'm like
dude I was right I don't need to lie on
your back yeah don't don't don't please
I [__] wait
myself
no no girl on bottom but she was she was
saying that girl like you're the girl
has her legs locked straight out and I
was like nobody's [__] like that you
want to pass out if you walk exactly I'm
like he's got to be a slight Bend to it
and that was the argument I used the
word up so she
said hey hey Elena's about form okay
on top she's like hey
go [__] with my form sorry
[Laughter]
she's like oh you're not a real man
you can't get in there oh you need me to
bend my knees oh I do have a little dick
no I got it
right now straighten up
[Laughter]
lock them up lock them lock the knees
I'll get in there dude